for our next caption contest I picked
this image that I took when I was
reorganizing books on my shelves and
they were scattered all over the place
in our bedroom slash library and uh
people had quite a few good quips and
comments to leave so we are going to
jump right into the captions now first
of all some people through poor sassy
underneath the bus and this is from a
time when sassy was still alive but she
was definitely not responsible for the
mess we see Alexander and learning with
Harry saying note to self don't allow
cats near bookcases and that Darn Cat no
it was not sassy it was all me so here's
my favorite one and it's it's a great
quip a great joke because it doesn't
come completely map onto things mirth
Quake it's a cool word and I think
there's kind of an interesting idea like
you know happiness somehow knocked
everything off the shelves so that's a
good one here's another good one this is
your brain on philosophy I think
everybody remembers those old
advertisements where it showed like an
egg cooking in a pan this is your brain
on drugs so this is your brain on
philosophy book strewn all over the
place and then there were a couple that
have to do with organization so this one
by KR reorganizing shelves so all the
spines are visible yes I think that
could be done right and sometimes I
shove books back onto the shelf and I'm
not paying close attention to whether
they are visible or not then we have a
longer one here by Virginia uh Charlotte
the philosophy of sorting hmm chronology
of publication station to a decimal
author surname spine height paperbacks
versus hardbacks date of acquisition
hanging all maybe rainbow color and
actually I don't use really any of those
some of the books are arranged
chronologically in terms of like period
you know ancient Medieval Renaissance
early modern later modern and in in
terms of like who came when but
sometimes there's less organization to
it as well now we start getting into
what I take to be Hegel references
although of course given that
phenomenology is used by a lot of people
this could be more like marilopon tea or
whoever quick kiwick says phenomenology
of Gregory's messy bookshelves and it is
indeed a phenomenology since you're
getting a look at something and getting
to linger over it right here's another
one clearly a another Hagel reference
the outer is not always an expression of
the inner like the skull doesn't
represent the brain the organization or
lack thereof of books doesn't represent
their content trivially true as a matter
fact looking at bookshelves really
unless you know what's in the books
already it doesn't tell you anything
about the content does it sometimes
people even have fake bookshelves don't
they here's another one if Hagel is on
one side oftentimes we picture deluses
being on a different side although they
actually kind of had some things in
common La creature says when to lose
orders your bookshelf in parentheses
it's a rhizome so you know rhizomes are
one of delusion guitars key ideas as a
matter of fact sometimes that's all that
people take from to lose everything
becomes a rise up so a rhizome is kind
of a connected mess you could say and
that that works here's the next one when
the search for being ends in the
disaster of having to clean up your mess
a little bit harder to pin to any
particular philosopher since so many of
them do talk about being the search for
being sounds rather existentialist and
cleaning up your mess is something that
we all have to do then this is an
interesting one and it's going to lead
us into several others from stino when
you know that you're right about
something but you can't remember where
you read it from and I I will admit that
I often do take books off of the Shelf
looking for something in particular and
then forget to put them back on the
shelf that table that you see in the
picture is a frequent staging area for
books and there were quite a few other
ones along similar lines so I wanted to
put them in here as you might call them
runners-up Derek London for [ __ ] sake
I know voltaire's Candide is in here
somewhere Sid I think I lost my Saint
Anselm again RLS I'm not even gonna try
to read the rest me when I can't find
Zara thustra's abysmal thought and then
Zeitgeist me tearing through the Barnes
and Noble philosophy section to find a
single primary source I guess this is a
common thing people looking for a
particular book and not often finding it
and then finally this is another great
one my second favorite one from bookish
Brendan her you have protection right
you hold on and what's the idea there
obviously there's no condom in the books
but walking into a place like that
should probably turn people off from
wanting to have sex with you and you
know unless they're into messy books
strewn all over the floor themselves
which I suppose could be a possibility
so those are the Roundup of what I
consider to be the best captions if you
want to get in on another one of these
contests you just have to wait a little
while in my YouTube channel and you
probably want to turn on notifications
for posts if you don't already have it
on some people say oh I missed this well
you you know you gotta like set yourself
up for success in that way so we'll have
more of these coming down the pike
thanks to everybody who contributed and
hope that you enjoy this